[Musik]
tatiana ist eine von rund 3000
leihmüttern aus der ukraine mit ihrer
zwölfjährigen tochter anastasia ist sie
aus dem bombenkrieg ihre heimatstadt
kiew nach warschau geflüchtet tatjana
ist in der 39 woche schwanger mit einem
baby das sie für ihre eltern austrägt
nun der hauptgrund ist natürlich die
bezahlung das gebe ich zu wie alle
anderen auch die du fragst verstehst du
du musst so viele schwierigkeiten
überwinden um zb ein haus zu kaufen
ich meine die situation in diesem land
ist schwierig du musst so vieles
überwinden wenn du jemanden hast um den
du dich kümmern muss
15.000 euro bekommt hat jana für die
leihmutterschaft für die ukrainerin sind
es mehr als drei jahresgehälter es ist
ein job gefühle für das baby muss sie
ausblenden
das ist nicht einfach man muss sich
wirklich darauf einstellen dass es nicht
das eigene baby ist und sich selbst
immer wieder einreden also du bist jetzt
ein container aber trotzdem ist das
natürlich schwer ich bin ein container
es ist nicht mein baby ich trage es nur
mit mir herum
der vorsorgetermin ist beendet dem baby
geht es gut sieben tage bleiben bis zum
geburtstermin
anstrengende wochen liegen hinter ihr
als der krieg begann sollte sie in kiew
auf die entbindung warten statt schutz
und unterstützung sagt sie bekamen sie
von der agentur diese anweisungen
[Musik]
behalten sie die dokumente den vertrag
bei sich man sagte mir ich solle nicht
nervös sein baldrian und magnesium b6
oder b12 nehmen es trinken und auf
weitere anweisungen warten
ihre leibliche zwölfjährige tochter ist
noch immer aktiv in ihrem heimatort bei
den großeltern oft im luftschutzbunker
wegen der bombenangriffe
tatjana will die tochter dort so schnell
wie möglich rausholen
mir wurde gesagt ich dürfe unter keinen
umständen gehen ich meine es ist mein
kind ich bin für zwei verantwortlich für
das kind das ich in mir trage und mein
eigenes
in haiti wird die situation unterdessen
immer dramatischer
ihre tochter schreibt
[Musik]
schließlich melden sich die irischen
wunsch eltern die eigentlich keinen
kontakt zu ihr haben dürften doch sie
hatten die agentur bedrängt zu groß war
ihre sorge um tatjana und das baby im
krieg
mit ihrer finanziellen unterstützung
holt tatjana ihre tochter aus dem
kriegsgebiet zwei tage lang fliegen die
beiden von hatif bis warschau
hier mieten ihr die wunsch eltern ein
appartement und zahlen seither die
untersuchungen und ihren lebensunterhalt
von der agentur bekommt sie keinerlei
finanzielle unterstützung mir
nach dieser behandlung durch die agentur
war ich in den ersten zwei wochen seit
meiner ankunft in polen deprimiert das
war unangenehm es tat psychisch de ich
wollte weinen weil es schlimm war was
sie mir angetan haben sie haben mich
einfach allein gelassen
was in anderen ländern verboten ist ist
in der ukraine legal die
leihmutterschaft gegen geld die
zahlungskräftigen paare kommen aus
kanada china deutschland das land ist
zur baby fabrik der welt geworden ein
geschäft mit millionenumsätzen im krieg
geht es weiter hier in kirow borat in
der zentrale ukraine warten die babys
auf ihre abholung
auch sie hat vor einigen tagen hier
entbunden die leihmutter will unerkannt
bleiben hier erwartet sie auf die
deutschen eltern die das baby trotz des
krieges abholen wollen sie ist nicht zum
ersten mal mutter
wissen sie es ist nicht leichter
geworden obwohl es schon das dritte mal
ist dass ich das machen
als eine frau sind gefühle da gott
vergibt das dem kind nichts geschehen
das ist geliebt wird und alles mit ihm
ja das sind die gefühle einer frau
aber ich versuche nicht daran zu denken
sie braucht das geld aus der
leihmutterschaft um ihre eigenen kinder
durchzubringen
in der nähe von köln machen sich die
deutschen wunsch eltern nix und patricia
auf den weg zu ihr in die zentral
ukraine
patrizia hat bereits ein kind aus einer
leihmutterschaft aus der ukraine
der wunsch nach einem weiteren war groß
noch trennen sie über 2500 kilometer von
ihrem baby sie müssen ins kriegsgebiet
eine lebensgefährliche reise vorbei an
militärposten grenzübergängen bis zur
klinik
angst habe ich total ausgeblendet wir
beide wir hatten ein ziel
da hinzufahren das kind raus zu holen
also angst hatte ich es gab sicherlich
momente wo mir gerade so an den grenzen
das weil wir die bahn schwer bewaffnet
die waren sehr skeptisch sehr muffelig
und dabei normalerweise in kriegszeiten
gehen da raus fährt und der verein fast
ganz bilde hier
dann ist es endlich soweit nach fünf
tagen fahrt kommen die deutschen wunsch
eltern patricia und ihr mann völlig
erschöpft in der zentral ukraine hier
treffen sie die leihmutter ihres babys
das erste mal persönlich
jetzt endlich das baby anschauen
[Musik]
es ist ein junger henry soll er heißen
auch der leibliche vater ist gerührt
[Musik]
für die leihmutter ist das emotional
kaum auszuhalten
die leihmutter soll mit ins
familienalbum in ein paar tagen werden
die wunsch eltern mit dem kleinen henry
die rückreise nach deutschland antreten
patricia will wissen wie das für die
leihmutter ist
der leihmutter kommen die tränen
[Musik]
ob sie noch einmal leihmutter sein will
fragt vertrieb
die wunsch eltern aus der nähe von köln
bekommen die dokumente der klinik
eigentlich bräuchten sie für die
grenzüberquerung noch den reisepass doch
in zeiten des krieges ist das
kompliziert und gefährlich sie werden
ohne fahren müssen
später erzählt uns die leihmutter wie
sie von der agentur unter druck gesetzt
wurde
als der krieg begann wurde sie aus kiew
zunächst nach hause geschickt doch dann
wurde sie gezwungen hochschwanger nach
kairo wurde in die zentral ukraine zu
reisen
[Musik]
ich durfte weil es so knapp war das baby
in der stadt in der ich lebte gewähren
dann sagten sie wieder ich könne nicht
dann wieder ich könne
schließlich aber sagten sie auf einmal
entweder du kommst zu uns oder du
bekommst du ein honorar nicht
um ihr geld zu bekommen hatte sie keine
wahlen drei tage vor der entbindung
machte sie sich auf den weg acht stunden
durchs kriegsgebiet voller angst um das
baby und ihr eigenes leben wird hier
gewinnen gemacht auf kosten der
sicherheit der leihmutter sind die
beiden einzelfälle wir wollen mehr
herausbekommen doch reden will kaum
jemand unsere quelle nennt ihr schreiben
uns
99 prozent der leihmutter in der ukraine
wollen momentan nicht vor der kamera
sprechen schließlich bekommen wir
kontakt zu einer leihmutter aus der ost
ukraine
sie will nicht vor der kamera mit uns
sprechen schreibt aber meine agentur hat
sich quasi aufgelöst aber gestern riefen
sie an und sagten dass ich nach kiew
gehen muss um dort zu entbinden stadt an
einen sicheren ort schicken sie mich
durch raketenfeuer und bomben um geld zu
sparen und ich habe angst um mein leben
lassen einige agenturen die leihmütter
während des krieges im stich setzen sie
sie unter druck der marktführer bei
attacks com wirbt auf seiner website
weiter und kunden als gäbe es keinen
krieg im land der so viele menschenleben
kostet
[Musik]
wir wollen von biotech.com wissen warum
das geschäft im krieg einfach
weiterläuft
wenn ich meinen wir weiter und wir haben
auch sehr viele intrigen interessent
ihnen die leihmütter ihn stehe und dann
die alte spenderinnen in spe und da wir
haben viele wunsch eltern jetzt die
einfach ein weiteres baby wünschen wie
sorgten bei text dafür dass die
leihmutter jetzt nicht zusätzlich
belastet werden also jetzt generell
unterwegs zu sein ist ja schon auch
lebensgefährlich oder ja natürlich uns
geht es in erster linie um nahm
um das leben und die gesundheit der
mutter und des kindes
natürlich du bist jetzt in der ukraine
in kiew oder wo bist du jetzt nein ich
bin nicht mehr in der ukraine genießen
sicherheit weil ich konnte das nicht
mehr aushalten offenbar hat die
pressesprecherin selbst das land
verlassen das hochumstrittene
geschäftsmodelle in kriegszeiten
verteidigt sie doch es sind die
leihmutter die den preis zahlt
wunsch mutter patricia ist mit baby
henry in deutschland angekommen als
nächstes steht die adoption bevor kein
einfacher prozess den leihmutterschaft
ist in deutschland verboten doch eins
lässt sie nicht los wieso musste die
leihmutter mit henry im bauch die
gefährliche reise durchs kriegsgebiet
machen die frage habe ich mir dann auch
gestellt aber natürlich
habe ich keine antwort bekommen und sie
ist nur der chef denn der arzt sagt muss
man dem folge leisten man kann nur von
glück sagen dass das alles glimpflich
gegangen ist also ich hab es gestern
oder heute
gelesen
dass genau und diese eisenbahn was rein
geflogen ist genau bei odessa
zurück zu lauter tatiana nach warschau
in wenigen tagen wird sie das kind zur
welt bringen und es den irischen eltern
übergeben wie lange sie danach in polen
bleibt ist unklar was machst du da
anastasia lernt schon mal polnisch
polnische ließ mir vor was hier steht
und übersetzte mal
im nachhinein sieht sie die
leihmutterschaft kritisch fühlt sich
ausgenutzt von ihrer agentur als sie
ihre hilfe benötigte haben sie tatjana
im stich gelassen
ich würde ihnen fahrlässigkeit gegenüber
leihmüttern vorwerfen
vielleicht hatten einige glück aber in
meinem fall haben sie es versäumt mich
gut zu behandeln
wir sind auch menschen haben auch
familien haben kinder um die wir uns
sorgen und schauen müssen dass sie
gesund bleiben
sie selbst will kein baby mehr austragen
für andere und nie mehr teil sein dieses
millionengeschäft das ohne erbarmen
weiterläuft auf kosten der leihmutter
[Musik]